American Media reporting that the
British novelist Martin Amos has sadly
died at the age of 73 he'd been
suffering from cancer for some time and
died at his home in Lake Worth in
Florida it was the same disease of
course that killed his close friend the
journalist Christopher Hitchens the
author published 15 novels a prolific
writer best known for his books at money
a suicide note and London feels the book
of prize has tweeted in the last few
minutes to say we are saddened to hear
that Martin Amos one of the most
acclaimed and discussed novelists of the
past 50 years has died our thoughts are
with his family and friends Martin Amos
was the son of novelist Kingsley Amos
who came to fame of course with his book
lucky Jim and died in 1995. Siobhan this
is very sad news this is very sad news
Martin name is I think defined a
generation a very particular male voice
of the the 1980s and 90s he was part of
a group that included as you just
mentioned there Christopher Hitchens uh
you could also mention Julian Barnes
rashti Ian McEwen um he was a prolific
writer
um I he not only books but also essays
in fact I was reading his uh Memoir
experience uh only a few months ago I
really uh absorbing reads uh that talks
about his relationship with his famous
father Kingsley Amos also talks about
his discovery of having a 17 year old
daughter that he didn't know about
Delilah and trying to to reconcile with
her
um and and also talking about uh his his
friendships and the fractured
friendships over the years he was very
successful at the time I mean a lot of
particularly young men found that they
they had a voice with Martin Amos um so
very sad news
um and 73 is no age
it really isn't the breaking news this
hour that the British author Martin Amos
has died after a cancer battle film and
TV journalist at many thanks for your
time